♪ [repetitive guitar music]
[drums and guitars]
[sing  'Good']
♪ In my head ♪
♪ it's all been laughter ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Could you be certain ♪
♪ What you've been searchin'
won't be late ♪
♪ [music]
♪ What you've been hopin' ♪
♪ could leave you broken ♪
♪ Don't be late ♪
♪ [music]
♪ 'Cause even when your cries stop ♪
♪ In my head ♪
♪ it's all I'm after ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Could you be certain ♪
♪ What you've been searchin'
won't be late ♪
♪ [music]
♪ What you've been hopin'
could leave you broken ♪
♪ Don't be late ♪
♪ [music]
♪ 'Cause even when your cries stop ♪
♪ 'Cause even when your cries stop
♪ [music]
♪ Wouldn't cut you off or even if I could ♪
♪ Confiscate your love or leave it
when I should ♪
♪ [music] ♪
♪ You've got a big heart maybe
start thinkingreturn Is it better to be ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Couldn't cast you off
or nobody's that good ♪
♪ Confiscate your love or leave it
when I should ♪
♪ You got a big heart maybe
start thinking return ♪
♪ Is it better to be on or be good? ♪
♪ Good ♪
♪ [music fast paced]
♪ [music slows]
[drums]
[sing 'Black Night']
♪ Black night blackness ♪
♪ When I wanted you,
how I haunted you ♪
♪ All to myself ♪
♪ [music]
♪ One gift, one slip ♪
♪ Where you're hiding at,
who you're aiming at ♪
♪ Won't kiss and tell ♪
♪ Control yourself ♪
♪ I don't want it to
I don't need it to ♪
♪ Can someone else ♪
♪ Counting until ♪
♪ When you're headin' to,
'cause your attitude ♪
♪ Turn on itself Kind heart,
kindness ♪
♪ Where you going to,
are you going through ♪
♪ Heaven or hell ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Won't slip, won't miss ♪
♪ When I'm on to you,
send it over to ♪
♪ Your faith in hell ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Control yourself I don't want it to, ♪
♪ I don't need it to ♪
♪ Contain myself, contain myself ♪
♪ It was never that I was aiming at ♪
♪ It means someone else ♪
♪ Ha ♪
♪ [music]
♪ You want it all. ♪
♪ You want to walk. ♪
♪ Crack through it. ♪
♪ You had it all. ♪
♪ You threw it. ♪
♪ You want it all. ♪
♪ You want to walk. ♪
♪ Crack through it. ♪
♪ You had it all. ♪
♪ You threw it. ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Black night.
Blackness. ♪
♪ When I wanted you,
how I haunted you ♪
♪ All to myself ♪
♪ [music]
♪ One kiss, one slip ♪
♪ Where you going to,
are you going through? ♪
♪ Heaven or hell ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Control yourself
♪ I don't want it to. ♪
♪ I don't need it to. ♪
♪ Can't someone else ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Counting until ♪
♪ When you need to,
'cause your attitude ♪
♪ Turn on itself ♪
♪ You want it all. ♪
♪ You want to walk. ♪
♪ Crack through it. ♪
♪ You had it all. ♪
♪ You threw it. ♪
♪ You want it all. ♪
♪ You want to walk. ♪
♪ Crack through it. ♪
♪ You had it all. ♪
♪ You threw it. ♪ ♪
♪ [music]
[applause]
[guitar tuning up]
♪ [music]
[sing 'When Will You Go']
♪ Who knew that you would follow me? ♪
♪ I think of you as highly guarded ♪
♪ It's easy when you call to me ♪
♪ I go to where I'm told I wanted them to. ♪
♪ Can't relate ♪
♪ To things back and forth ♪
♪ Can disintegrate ♪
♪ So why do you ask me? ♪
♪ When will you go? ♪
♪ Nothing's permanent, ♪
♪ I thought you know ♪
♪ Why do you ask me? ♪
♪ When will you go? ♪
♪ Nothing's permanent, ♪
♪ I thought you know ♪
♪ [music]
♪ I'll take you where you hold your fears ♪
♪ I'll show you what you know, but can't see ♪
♪ I'll keep you where I know you'll be ♪
♪ I'll show you what it means
to be discarded and put to the side ♪
♪ Like things back and forth
and can't integrate ♪
♪ So why do you ask me
when will you go? ♪
♪ Nothing's permanent. ♪
♪ I thought you know ♪
♪ Why do you ask me
when will you go? ♪
♪ Nothing's permanent. ♪
♪ I thought you know ♪
♪ [music]
♪ [guitar]
♪ Is this your last call to me? ♪
♪ I hope it is ♪♪
♪ [music]
♪ [guitar]
[applause]
Meric Long: Thanks.
Thanks for letting us come and play
on your heavenly campus here.
We did steal some people's bikes
and ride around.
I hope nobody noticed.
Logan Kroeber: It was the yellow one
with the red and green tires.
♪ [guitar]
[drums and tambourine join]
[sing 'Companions']
♪ Insipid wait and so we play ♪
♪ Companions ♪
♪ No story games,
could you behave? ♪
♪ Companions Oh ♪
♪ I'll hold you in, you're holding out ♪
♪ If I can wait, could you be mine? ♪
♪ Companions. ♪
♪ Are we the same? ♪
♪ Could we behave as companions ♪
♪ Oh... ♪
♪ [music]
♪ I'll hold you in. ♪
♪ You're holding out. ♪
♪ [music]
[applause]
[guitar tuning]
[drums]
[drums and guitars playing]
[sing 'Winter'] ♪ Don't know if I'll make it
through this winter without you by my side ♪
♪ I waited here for you so long
while traveled far and wide ♪
♪ Convinced myself there's no one better,
so how could I deny ♪
♪ Your love,
it's like a thorn into my side ♪
♪ My friends they understand me better
but don't whisper goodnight ♪
♪ I want a lover and a sister,
but we know that's not right ♪
♪ You used to listen to my music,
I always wondered why ♪
♪ I wish I could pretend you make me try ♪
♪ [music]
♪ I want the days to come, ♪
♪ I want these sleepless nights to end ♪
♪ I lie here thinking how I lost you
to all your stupid friends ♪
♪ You made me feel so foolish
for the twenty-second time ♪
♪ Your love might be the last time that I try ♪
♪ Don't know if I'll get through this winter
without you on my own ♪
♪ I waited here for you forever,
I can't believe you'd go ♪
♪ I may not have the answers,
but I'd rather never know ♪
♪ Your love was such
a heavy, heavy blow ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Goodnight my love, you seemed so nice
'til I knew you better ♪
♪ Now I can tell you're always thinking
twice about what might be better ♪
♪ On the outside,
there's no conscience, ♪
♪ you're a victim of your cautiousness ♪
♪ You don't try, ♪
♪ and you just lie there hoping that
someone will come to make it right ♪♪
♪ [music]
[applause]
[sounds of guitars tuning] [pause]
Meric Long: We're gonna do
one more song for you guys.
Here we go.
[guitar]
[drums, music]
[sing 'Fools']
♪ Our father's been entangled in things ♪
♪ He's been squandering,
he's been squandering ♪
♪ And we don't do a thing,
'cause we're busy and think ♪
♪ We're just wandering,
we're just a-wandering like fools ♪
♪ Fools... ♪
♪ His son is his prize,
he tells a few lies ♪
♪ He's got his father's eyes,
it's in his father's eyes ♪
♪ And he thinks in his mind
that he's just getting by ♪
♪ But he's a compromise,
he's just a compromising ♪
♪ Fools... ♪
[music]
♪ And the stance that
we take isn't much to bear ♪
♪ Yeah, we leave things
to change on their time ♪
♪ And our failure to care for
it leaves us blind ♪
♪ 'til we're tired
and we're crazed in the mind ♪
♪ Ya ha, Ya ha, Ya ha, Ya ha ♪
♪ [music]
♪ Now he lies on his back,
and they tell him it's that ♪
♪ It's just a heart attack,
it's just a heart attack ♪
♪ Too late to return to the ones
that you've earned ♪
♪ No they don't give it back,
no they don't give it back to fools ♪
♪ Fools... ♪
♪ [music]
♪ And the stance that
we take isn't much to bear ♪
♪ Yeah, we leave things
to change on their time ♪
♪ And our failure to care
for it leaves us blind ♪
♪ 'til we're tired and
we're crazed in the mind ♪
♪ Ya ha, Ya ha, Ya ha, Ya ha
♪ I've been, I've been silent ♪
♪ I've been, I've been silent ♪♪
[applause]
Meric Long: Thanks.
Logan Kroeber: We'll be playing
at the Fillmore tonight
and if anybody lives in San Francisco
or if you know anybody that does.
Thanks.
Female Presenter: Once again,
the Dodos.
Thanks so much for making the drive
down to Mountain View.
[applause]
So Meric and Logan have kindly
offered to stick around
for some questions from the audience.
So those of you who want to ask a question
just line up to the microphone here
and I'll kick it off by first asking why you
guys always get classified as folk music
when you're so wonderfully loud
and plugged in?
Meric Long: Well, this is a recent
amalgamation of our band.
We started out as just acoustic guitar
and one Tom duo, one floor Tom.
Our earlier stuff is I think closer to folk
music but with each successive record,
we've fallen into the [laughs] the cliché of
strapping on electrics and getting louder.
Female Presenter: Yeah.
And for those of you who can't see
I just want to make sure everyone took
note of the wonderful percussion,
foot percussion going on with Logan.
[laughs]
The tambourine on the foot.
[applause]
Logan Kroeber: Give it up for old Tambi.
[audience laughter]
Audience Member: Tambi.
Female Presenter: [laughs] So how did
that come about?
Just lack of arm space?
Logan Kroeber: I just wanted to look at it.
[laughter]
On our first record, there was a song
we had done live
and I was doing something with my hands
and I didn't have a tambourine to hit.
So I put it on the floor.
And at first I would stomp on it with no--
nothing to fix it to my foot
and that didn't work very good.
So I would actually duct tape it
to my foot every show
and that was stupid so
[audience laughter] I made a shoe.
Female Presenter: Any plans for a custom
version of that coming out soon?
Logan Kroeber: If there was demand.
[laughter]
I'd be happy to put my name on it.
Female Presenter: So on your new record,
'No Color',
you feature the lovely vocals
of Neko Case.
How did that collaboration come about?
Meric Long: We were toying with her band,
The New Pornographers, over the summer
and she lost a poker bet.
[audience laughs]
Meric Long: So she had to come sing
on our record. [audience laughter]
Female Presenter: Any plans
to do more with her?
Or have the Dodos perform
on her next record?
Meric Long: There was some talk of that
but we're just waiting for that phone call.
Desperately.
[laughter]
Female Presenter: But she sings
a lot of songs though.
So it must have been a pretty good bet.
Meric Long: Yes because it was,she came in
for two days and just like went wild and yeah.
I think she sang on more stuff but--
it happened so fast
[laughter]
Female Presenter: Cool.
Lucky.
Let's take a question from the crowd.
Is there some,yep.
Male #1: Yeah.
On the new record,
it seems like you guys have
a much heavier guitar sound.
Could you maybe explain
why that came about?
And also could you explain the genesis
of the new album title, 'No Color'?
Meric Long: Question 1, the one of
the things that we wanted to make sure
we did on this record was
have lots of time to record.
Because in the past,
it has been just like go in,
record the songs as fast as possible.
And one of the by-products of
that was sort of sitting around
with a bunch of pretty finished songs
but wanting to add something else.
And there having just a bunch
of electric guitars lying around.
So I ended up playing a lot of that
and it was actually,
it was super great and fun for me.
Because like I actually started out on
the electric guitar and I had forgotten that
'cause I had been playing acoustic
and focusing on that for so long
that I had forgotten that
I even knew how to play it.
During the process of doing that,
twiddling knobs and working with pedals,
I stumbled upon the sacred Billy Corrigan tone
and I was really,that ended up being
streamlined to most of the songs.
And we just added more and more guitars and
ended up with whatever you hear.
And the album title I will defer to him.
Logan Kroeber: Question 2.
I--
when we play certain songs,
like we just played 'Fools'.
'Fools' to me is blue in my mind when I play it.
Right?
And so [laughter]
There's lots of other songs that we play that I
have imagery or colors that I associate with it.
And when we were doin' 'No Color',
we were towards the end
of the mixing process.
We were listening to the songs every day.
And I had imagery and colors for the songs
but it was all just like gray.
Ashy and kind of like a campfire
that burned out kind of look
and I told everybody over dinner one night.
And it sounds bad when you say,
it's like, 'Oh. "The Season" is red.
Or "Long Form is orange".'
Or whatever.
And it's like everything here is gray.
It sounds kind of bad
but it is just what it was
and Meric and I were driving
back to San Francisco
after we finished the record
and we were just talkin',
'What should we name it?'
And we were trying to come up with a good
way to encapsulate that phenomenon
and that was the best we could come up with.
Male  #1: Thank you.
Female #1: So you've
also lost the vibraphone on this record.
And I wanted to ask how that's
affected the time and the travel
on your current tour and
what that must have been like?
I actually saw you guys in an airport once
and you were waiting [laughs].
And I thought,
'Oh yeah. The vibraphone.
How do they get that
from show to show to show?'
Meric Long: We're,well,
I'm sure our vibraphonist is happy
that he doesn't have to pack that up
and put it together every night anymore.
It's,we just got this like portable vibraphone
that has like 30 pieces
and you have to put it together.
And it wasn't the most practical
choice of instrument
but we sort of [laughs] really wanted to have
vibraphone in the band for whatever reason.
And yeah, we,that's--
I mean it's nice that we don't--
our set up's a lot more simpler now.
But that was one of those things that also sort
of happened during recording the new record.
We were just-- started to take off
stuff and mix stuff differently.
And by the end of the record being done,
we had an entire record
with no vibraphone.
So that's why it's not here.
[laughter]
Female Presenter: So you're from the Bay Area.
You're from San Francisco and
you've been described as 'music nerds',
'San Francisco music nerds.'
Now that you're here at Google
with all the other nerds,
can you speak to the use of technology
either in promoting your music
or putting out your music?
Creating music?
Meric Long: I recently
purchased a Nintendo DSi.
[audience laughter]
and [laughs] in between long hours
of Mario Brothers,
I've actually discovered or Chris,
the other guitarist,
Hi, he lent me a game that's
like a Korg synthesizer
that's pretty amazing actually.
And I've been looking for another
copy of the game
so we could have two Nintendo DSis up here
and just plug in the amps
and just have part of
the show where we just play video games.
[laughter]
But it's hard.
It's really hard.
It's a hard game to find.
Female Presenter: Anybody has
any tips after the show?
Another question.
Female #2: Sure.
First of all, thanks so much for coming.
That was really fun.
Related to the question about
being from San Francisco.
Welcome back and welcome home.
I wonder if you guys have your favorite San
Francisco or Bay Area spots that you visit
when you're in town?
Meric Long: Uhh.
Hello.
Food wise?
[laughs]
Female #2: Anything wise.
Meric Long: The first thing
I'm gonna do when,
we're actually going down to L.A.
and coming back.
When I come back the first thing I'm doing is
probably gonna go to Mission Chinese Food
and get my fill of Ma Po Tofu.
That's all I got.
[laughs]
[audience laughter]
That's all I do when I'm here.
Logan Kroeber: That place is pretty good.
I haven't had the Ma Po Tofu
'cause it's really spicy supposedly.
It's got three little flaming buns next to it.
[audience chuckles]
Meric Long: [laughs] You will.
You will pay.
Female Presenter: No burritos?
Burritos?
Logan Kroeber: Burritos for sure.
I've been more on this Colombian kick.
There's a place that's across from
the Mission Street City College Campus
that's right across the way.
And I've been going there and getting like,
they make like fresh soup
and papusas and stuff.
That's where I'm gonna go.
Female Presenter: I wanted to ask
a question about the latest video
because it's a little different than videos
I've seen of the Dodos in the past.
You must have performed.
And this video in particular is very dramatic.
If you wanna maybe describe it a little bit
and how that came about starring
in your video for Black Night.
Meric Long: We have the director right here.
Logan Kroeber: All right.
I'm gonna try and keep this brief.
[laughs]
On that same car ride where we were
talkin' about namin' the record 'No Color',
I also unleashed all my video ideas on Meric
that I'd been stockpiling for the past year.
And for those who haven't seen the video,
it's a,like, it's kinda like blood sport,
Van Damm type of vibe.
Well, that's how it originally started.
But it was originally, originally just
gonna be me and Meric in a boxing ring
with like a three round match.
And I'm glad we decided
[laughs] not to do that.
Shirtless on camera for five minutes
is not the best.
So instead we went the blood sport route,
got a bunch of our friends involved
to be sort of different,
sort of like fighting characters,
stereotypes, and I don't know.
It was an insane experience.
I've never tried to sort of put a creative idea in
visually or like motion picture into action before
and it's like,it's kind of addicting
that I really want to try again
'cause it didn't turn out
how I wanted to exactly.
Like the thing in my head was not the same
as what is on YouTube right now.
Female Presenter: Yeah.
What's missing?
Logan Kroeber: Blood.
[laughter]
Logan Kroeber: We shot it in black and white
and supposedly you can use
chocolate syrup as fake blood
when you are shooting in black and white.
And we ran out of time and we didn't
get to do any of the actual contact.
We just shot a bunch of like the people
pacing around, you know what I mean?
There's supposed to be some payoff.
Female Presenter: Wow.
[laughs]
Next question.
Male #3: I just want to say
thanks again so much for coming.
It is awesome to see you guys here.
So keeping the San Francisco
line of questioning.
You guys obviously got your start
in San Francisco.
And I'm curious now that
you guys have gotten a lot bigger
and have toured around the country,
just sort of how you kind of got
your beginnings in San Francisco.
How the San Francisco music scene
compares to other music scenes
you've seen around the country.
And sort of what that transition like process
has been from being relatively unknown
to getting a break here and there and
kind of how your life is different?
Logan Kroeber: What was
the first place you played?
Solo.
Meric Long: Ahh. There's a place,
there's a restaurant called,
I don't remember actually.
Logan Kroeber: The one that you played
at every week?
Meric Long: Yeah.
No.
Once a month.
Meric Long: Solstice.
There you go.
There's a restaurant called Solstice
and that was my first gig.
They gave me a hundred bucks to play
for two hours
while people were stuffing their faces
and [laughs] and then I just started,
I started playing a lot of the songs
from our first record
and writing and playing out.
And then we started doing
shows together and then we,
the first sort of like tour we did was,
our manager at the time,
she was a good booking agent,
like that's one thing that she could
do really well was book us a tour
and so we would just like,
we both had jobs that were really like lenient
with us taking some time off which was good.
And we would just tour across
the country like literally playing
to four or five people every night
in some crappy bar.
But I think, but after doing that for a year,
we ended up recording a record
and writing songs on the road
and that record became 'Visitor' and
that was sort of our first breakthrough.
Our first record that we put out with the label
that got some attention and got reviewed.
And what was the secondpart
of your question? [laughs]
Female Presenter: One more question
Male #4: I don't see a merch table.
I do see a table but there's
no merchandise on the table.
Do you,are you selling
anything here like records?
Meric Long: We can.
Male #4: You can?
[laughter]
Logan Kroeber: There'll be a parking lot party
[laughter] in twenty minutes.
Male #4: In twenty minutes.
Okay.
Female Presenter: Well thanks again
for driving down here and again,
tonight's performance is at the Fillmore,
the Reading Rainbow, for those of you
who want to see a double dose of the Dodos.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
Meric Long: Thanks
00:45:02.733,00:00:00.000